[Music]
this is a special edition of your money
briefing for Friday April 14th I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
on this episode we're taking a closer
look at those mortgage rates which can
pave the way toward moving into a new
home or Price buyers out hopefully they
come back down for people yeah we have
two kids that eventually will need to
buy houses and I just don't see what the
current rates like how that's ever going
to happen so where do you begin the
search for an attractive rate when you
are getting a mortgage you're definitely
not committed to that national average a
lot of Bank websites will allow you to
browse the different types of mortgages
that are offered and the rates that
they're offering and real estate agents
will often offer referrals to local
lenders too my guest is Holden Lewis
he's a senior writer at NerdWallet who
focuses on mortgages and home buying hey
Holden thank you for joining us hey
thank you so first of all Holden help us
with the basics here what are the
different kinds of mortgages out there
and what kind of an agreement does the
borrower sign there are two main types
of mortgages there's the fixed rate
mortgage and then a adjustable rate
mortgages and
north of 90 percent of borrowers get
fixed rate loans so you know what that
means is you're paying the same interest
rate over the life of the loan usually
that's 30 years and so your monthly
payments stay about the same with an
adjustable rate mortgage the interest
rate stays the same for the first few
years usually five and then after that
the interest rate can go up and down
every six months so those are the two
main types of mortgages all right but
wouldn't it make sense then to sign up
for the fixed rate mortgage and have the
same amount every month you know so
there aren't any surprises deciding on
whether to get a fixed rate mortgage or
an adjustable which is also called an
arm it's really an issue of personal
temperament
you or I might prefer to avoid the risk
of our mortgage payments Rising along
with the interest rates but a lot of
gamblers are out there you know and they
prefer to get the lower payments now on
an arm with the possibility that rates
and payments could drop in a few years
and in the meantime those folks are
saving money
one of the advantages of an adjustable
rate mortgage or arm is that the initial
interest rate is lower than what you can
get on a fixed rate mortgage and
therefore you're saving money in those
first few years versus someone who got a
fixed rate loan and then what happens to
that more attractive interest rate let's
say you get a five-year arm
the interest rate stays the same for the
first five years and then it adjusts up
or down every six months after that and
it's pegged to something called sulfur
the secured overnight Finance rate and
So lately that has been going up it's
gone up pretty steeply it's gone up
about six tenths of a percentage point
so far this year so someone who got a
sofa or five years ago they would be
seeing their interest rate going up
right now but we don't know what's going
to happen in five years it's possible
that interest rates could be falling
five years from now and someone who gets
an arm now might actually see their
interest rate go down when it starts
adjusting in five years we just don't
know I mean it's also very possible that
that rate could be going up in five
years
so arms are really well suited for
people who think that they're going to
sell the home within a few years or
someone who is just kind of starting out
in life they think that they're going to
move in the first five years or so
because their family is going to expand
or they're going to start earning a lot
more money that might be worth the
gamble because they expect to get out of
that house in a few years anyway all
right then with regard to the fixed
mortgage rates each week it's usually on
a Thursday we hear about how the average
30-year mortgage rate ticked up or down
over the past week what does that mean
for prospective home buyers so you're
talking about the Freddie Mac index
and it's really good for tracking the
trends just whether interest rates are
going up or down but don't expect your
lender to offer exactly the rates
reported in Freddie Mac's weekly survey
and that's because the survey is
conducted early in the week and then
it's reported on Thursdays so first of
all the data might be stale but also
that survey mixes
rates on loans with discount points and
without discount points with a discount
point it's an upfront fee that you pay
to the lender to reduce your interest
rate usually one percent of your loan
amount will reduce the interest rate by
one quarter of a percentage point
so let's say you're getting a three
hundred thousand dollar loan if you pay
two points that would be six thousand
dollars
that would be two percent of the loan
amount so you'd be paying six thousand
dollars up front and you might reduce
your interest rate by about
half a percentage point
and that can really save you a lot of
money if you keep that house for say
five or six years or longer so when
someone does go down the path of
discount points is there room for
negotiation there is not room for
negotiation with
an individual lender but what you can do
is apply at several different lenders
three is a good number
and find out the deals that they're
offering on discount points and one of
those lenders might be offering a better
deal on that day or even at that hour so
that is the best way to
shop for the best deal on discount
points you always keep in mind as a
buyer that the negotiation isn't only
about the house price the negotiation
can also include elements of the
financing so
you can actually ask you can just
proactively ask hey to the seller or to
the home builder will you please pay
some discount points home builders are a
little bit more eager nowadays to offer
discount points because frankly there's
just more homes being built and being
completed than there are homeowners who
are putting their houses for sale you
can also negotiate on things like your
move-in date or the homeowners move out
date and things like can you store items
in their garage before they move out all
of these things are subject to
negotiation so don't get stuck only on
the price now it's time to start the
search for the best mortgage rate coming
up we'll discuss when it makes sense to
use a mortgage broker and hear from
homeowners about their Journey
all right so how should people begin the
search for a mortgage and are they
beholden to the national average here's
more of my conversation with nerd
wallets Holden Lewis
when you are getting a mortgage you're
definitely not committed to that
national average so a good place to
start is just online a lot of Bank
websites or a lot of sites like nerd
wallet will allow you to browse the
different types of mortgages that are
offered and the rates that they're
offering and real estate agents will
often offer referrals to local lenders
too
and the real estate agents they're not
really looking out for you in terms of
finding a lender for you who offers the
lowest rate
what the real estate agent wants is the
lender who is responsive
offers good customer service and above
all is the most likely to actually close
that loan someone who's thorough who
isn't going to come up with nasty last
minute surprises because you know that
just that's not what real estate agents
want to happen they want that loan that
that closing on the house to go through
on time and Holden Lindsay from Clifton
New Jersey who we heard from earlier
really crystallized the importance of
finding a good rate against dealing with
all of their other expenses and so for
us it was all about having a good
efficient person it didn't matter to us
what bank it was through
we often hear about mortgage brokers in
the home buying process what exactly do
they do mortgage brokers look for a
mortgage for you
a broker has relationships with multiple
lenders so they can take your
application information and then shop
that information to multiple lenders in
search of the best deal that's different
from say going to your local bank where
you make a mortgage application and
you're applying with just that one
lender mortgage broker just simply has
these relationships with different
lenders and they can look at different
what are called rate sheets which are
the rates offer but also with fees taken
into account
so they take your application
information
and apply it to those different lenders
and they search for that best deal why
would somebody use a mortgage broker and
why would somebody not use a mortgage
broker people would use a mortgage
broker because they might have a really
complicated Financial life that's one
real big reason for using a broker for
example let's say you're self-employed
and you have a pretty complicated tax
form
mortgage brokers they can spend more
time assessing your financial position
and they know which lenders are willing
to do alone for someone with kind of
that that complicated Financial life
for people like me who are just I have a
job I get a W-2 form everything is
really straightforward that's kind of a
plain vanilla mortgage I can get that at
a regular old bank I could find one
through a broker but if I were
self-employed and I had a company
vehicle and I had tax deductions related
to that and all sorts of complex ways to
just count what my income is a mortgage
broker might be a better bet how would a
prospective home buyer using a mortgage
broker how would they be charged for the
broker Services the mortgage broker
works on commission so they collect a
commission from the bank that's really
not all that different from say a loan
officer at a bank who gets paid a salary
and those costs those commissions or
those salaries essentially you know you
end up paying for those when you close
the loan in terms of
fees and the mortgage rate so going
through the process of getting a
mortgage is it common for people to work
with more than one lender and should
they do that absolutely people should
apply with multiple lenders there has
been research on this Freddie Mac has
conducted it at least twice where they
find that if you apply with at least
three lenders you tend to get a better
deal than someone who applies with just
one lender we're talking about lower
mortgage rates we're talking about lower
fees so the advice is to always
comparison shop it's a good idea to
apply with at least three lenders and or
Brokers to find the best deal and so
that comes down to the competition
between the lenders and the Brokers
that's right there is competition
some lenders just charge more and some
charge less and really that can vary day
to day and even hour to hour
it's a very fluid market and so the best
thing to do is not only to apply with at
least three lenders or Brokers but also
to try to do that in the same day
because those different mortgage offers
they change day to day but you know
Holden ever since home prices began to
rise significantly it's been rough for
first-time buyers are there programs
geared toward them to help make this
process a little smoother there are a
lot of programs for first-time home
buyers some of them aren't specifically
for buyers I'm talking about the VA
which is a program administered by the
Department of Veterans Affairs and FHA
Loans which are loans that are insured
by the federal housing Administration
those mortgages are good for people who
might not have high credit scores like
something below 720 and they offer
really good deals as far as minimum down
payments you don't have to make a down
payment on a VA loan and the minimum
down payment on an FHA loan is three and
a half percent so on top of that every
state in Washington DC and some big
cities have first-time homebuyer
programs they'll give you grants
or loans to cover your closing costs or
they might offer subsidized mortgage
rates all right that's nerd wallets
Holden Lewis with us Holden thanks very
much for joining us you're welcome it's
my pleasure finding the best mortgage is
a big piece of the puzzle but there's
still plenty of room for error next week
on the fourth episode of our home buying
series we'll discuss costly and common
mistakes made by buyers and how to avoid
them
and that's it for your money briefing
this week we were produced by Ariana
osparu in motion Ali today's episode was
mixed by Jess Fenton our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley
editorial support provided by philana
Patterson I'm your host J.R Whalen
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]